again the untimely death of alekhine so
the question is what to do how to
resolve the current situation and the
feed a decided well it was time for them
to react to respond and from all around
the world at that time the delegates of
all of the national countries got
together to make the determination of
what to do
for the World Championship so very few
people actually know this but the feed a
convened their general Congress they got
together and they determined the most
sensible thing to do was to make dr. max
Eartha the world champion because he
held the world championship he lost it
to Alekhine Alekhine dies
they give the world championship title -
max irva it passed so it was official
max erver was the world champion did the
Soviet delegates delegation arrived a
day late so they weren't on the original
vote and they say hey wait a minute wait
wait wait a minute wait a timeout let's
do this whole thing again
let's open up for consideration blah
blah blah and Max irva didn't feel that
he deserved to be world champion I mean
okay I mean yeah I mean if you force it
on me but it's not like you know I the
best player anything let's organize an
event
to determine the best player that was
where the five top players bought Vinick
smyslov Kara's max irva and Bob Vinick
was the runaway winner I mean it was
clear that he won and then the idea this
whole 3-year cycle that continued all
the way up to Bobby Fischer and Anatoly
Karpov Garry Kasparov etc so Bob
vinick's a world champion now they gotta
find him a challenger and instead of
willy-nilly I'll accept you I won't
accept you they organized these inter
zonal and candidates tournament and
David Bronstein was the Challenger so
this was the first match under the new
cycle the non Alekhine cycle and again
you got to kind of place yourself in the
and the mindset of the two players
Michael bought Vinick was this
extraordinary Lee determined severe
scientific correct Orthodox man I mean
he was the the Soviets prototype you
know of correct play correct behavior
correct thought versus David Bronstein
yeah the root of all evil
the total creative tactically genius guy
who's just doing I mean you can't David
was just an amazing amazing person and
it has been a great honor and a pleasure
to have many many many conversations
with David and to be able to analyze
with him I unfortunately never played
against David we analyzed a lot but well
there you go and so here we have mr.
correct versus mr. incorrect okay we've
all done this on the worlds
stage david blunders a whole rock ah ah
do I resign that moved him he's a look
down a hole rubdown do I resign it move
ten and the shortest loss of you know
World Championship history or do I just
struggle on for a few more moves until
my opponent kills me well let's find out
shall we
this is a very funny game d 4 e 6 e 4f
fine in the 1951 match extraordinarily
enough it was like both players like to
play the Dutch and they were arguing
about this position with colors reversed
earlier decades earlier you will recall
that josé raúl capablanca and Alexander
Alekhine in their match like 30 out of
the 36 games where Queen's Gambit
declines you know now they had moved
further now they were into Dutch
territory okay so the consideration at
that time was the best way to counter
the Dutch was to fianchetto the King's
Bishop so here we go
Bishop d7 now what had happened earlier
in their matches is that earlier games
from their matches from this position
what Bronstein was doing was playing d6
Queen to e8
and oftentimes heading for a five so
what Bob benek did is to cross up his
opponent to get him out of that scheme
of d6 Queen e8 maybe Queen comes to h5
he made the tempo space caning move d5
right away
okay so what his idea was is that when
the pawn was back if he had played
Knight f3 d6 castles Queen e8 it wasn't
easy for him to play e4 what he really
wants from David is he wants to see the
movie 5 so that he could then play efore
where it's much easier for him to play E
for now then when the night is on f3 so
that's what he wants
so the mind of Braunstein comes Bishop
before everything okay I'll I'll stutter
it up to step my way to the B Foursquare
and I'll invite a queen trade of white
once that okay Bishop b4 Bishop d2 e 5
so now you know the desirable e4 has
issues that is to say I can take and
take on e4 I get a good night in the
middle of the board so e 2 e 3 D 7 D 6
night here a 6 in my opinion this was a
bad move okay let's see just a second
hold on where's my glasses I want to
make sure that the line I gave it's in
here yes okay good okay so this is
typical Bronstein trying to be creative
okay in fact the positions not bad for
black at all it's not bad for white it's
very clear that white intends to play a3
Bishop takes to recapture either with a
knight or with the bishop it's not so
certain which is the best way to capture
that you win the two bishops and so
forth and so on
so if you look at the position from the
point of view of the
on structure it's rather clear that
blacks play by and large really is
directed kingside so ideas like f5f for
in the position he 5e for you can bring
a knight to the e5 square and so forth
and so on but Bronstein comes up with a
six like what's that suddenly you know
David wants to play on the Queen side
with b5 which is actually White's
provenance
thanks to this c4 part I don't like that
move I think the best move was that
pardon me I think the best move was
actually Knight a6 will display a few
moves that I thought were sensible ones
let's say a three let's say trade trade
let's say b4 so now you've got you know
your bishop on this night you've won the
two bishops you got this bishop there
you got ideas f3 you've got other ideas
maybe like f4 to open up that diagonal
but it's blacks turn Knight g4 White has
an issue on the f2 pawn castles are not
Queen g5 I thought that this was a very
harmonious play for both sides because
it's very clear that you know as white
wants to play c5 black wants to play
over here on the King side and open
things up I I felt the position was
rather balanced dynamically balanced
that's not what happened instead we had
a six and now the very correct mod
Vinick is completely out of his normal
routines he comes up with a bad move
he plays Queen c2 much simpler was to
simply play Queen oops
simpler was
where's my where's my annotation oh ok
notation up there simpler was a three
tags tags night bd7
and I think black is doing okay
reasonably so and I think that this is
more or less I'm not going to say dead
even or anything like that it's it's
balanced it's weird
black has an idea of ePHI the e4 Knight
to e5 and putting his knight nicely in
the center of the board
not what bought Vinik did in my opinion
by Vinick made a poor decision with the
move Queen c2 and he didn't understand
that the idea of a6 had two ideas the
first idea is to play for b5 obviously
what David is playing for the second
idea was that David wanted to put his
Bishop on a7 like hmm Queenie 8 f2 f3
already I'm not too sure if I like that
move either b5 Queen b3 Bishop c5 now I
don't know what you can call this
defense but you can't call it a king's
indian love it that Bishop is about as
you will see is about to go pay seven
bishop to a7 now comes one of the most
humorous moments in chess history the
move Bishop a seven was simply wrong
David should have played a B Knight
takes e5 B takes e5 and I actually like
blacks position I think black is doing
okay but what he played instead it was a
howler Bishop back b6 Bishop takes a
four
v7 whoops oh dear there goes the rook
like okay now you know you're red-faced
and shame because again you're playing
on the world stage you got a thousand
people watching you and you're just like
one of the world's best players and you
just blunder to run now
it certainly has happened to me and
perhaps it's happened to you as well so
at this moment besides the natural
feelings of self-loathing complete
disgust that you might have for yourself
you really have to change your mindset
when you blundered horribly and you've
been you're behind what your mindset has
to be is Europe you know your opponent's
winning you know you're lost he knows
you're lost and he wants his life to be
as easily easy peasy
and what your job is is to make small
victories you need to make small small
victories by creating problems for your
opponent so here you are at the moment
black is an exchange down but both
bishops are hanging so he's going to be
a rook down so if I can ask the class
you're faced this position you're you're
black you're facing this position what
can you do what can you do to make
White's life that much more
uncomfortable you can resign but that's
not what we want we want them we want to
create problems for white Julian
so maybe you know first of all let's
look you could play the move Bishop
takes d5 that gets a pawn for the rook
Bishop takes d5 Queen takes attacking
this pawn I don't think black White's
going to have any problems converting
the game right so you've got so if
Bishop takes d5 Queen takes a7 means
lights out down the road you've got to
find a way of making White's difficult
life difficult this should be six so now
you're thinking as black that if you can
maintain this guy this guy this guy is
this guy White's queen is in a box yeah
okay Bravo takes
like to do with black what to do what
can we do
Giuliana get sure queen-to-be what
exactly so Queen to b5 this is basically
your only way of annoying white from
just castling consolidating his position
now you're I don't I'm not a hundred
percent sure you want to take that pawn
maybe you do maybe you you know you give
the Queen but at least you harassed the
night you don't make it comfortable for
your opponent to castle you harass the
pawn and so forth and so on now here I
think bod Vinick went wrong and he
played the move Knight c3 that basically
is an invitation to capture the pawn
Knight c3 is fine
white is still winning I mean it's not
even close but if I were in white shoes
I would think that b4 sorry let me just
put this on the moon position Knight
takes Knight c3 would have been a nice
way to essentially kind of I mean again
I mean I'm a rook ahead I've
consolidated maybe on a good day I will
play Bishop f1 and bring my queen to the
d5 square with a check and okay it's a
little you know there's a small disc of
discomforts but it's a it's a whole rook
but again from blacks point of view
black has to think how to how to create
cosmic Creek chaos how to give my
opponents problems okay so now you've
got a pawn and maybe on a good day if
the King goes in that way you got an F
for you know just to create problems
just to create problems so Bob Vinick
who's a whole
look ahead master of correctness and
everything else he decides to take the
victory right away he plays rook takes a
sex now this actually is a move that
black has to welcome in the sense if we
go back here for a moment
basically that knight on b8 is stock for
as long as you can imagine you know like
that Knight stock from whites point of
view white says hey I'll give back a
little material give back an exchange
instead of being a rook up I'm happy to
be a piece up because I'm completely
winning which is true however it helps
blacks position a lot like that's a
small victory you've now blundered a
rook you've won an exchange back okay
you've also won upon so what I thought
but then it should have done was Castle
just simply Castle it's like one of
those situations where you know your
biggest fear is your opponent will do
that
well you encourage them to do that f4
there's nothing else for black to do
that could harass white you defend the
pawn and that's it that's all that's
happening you could take this pawn on be
too but after rook a to you're stopped
so I play Knight here takes and here
I've given up two pawns but I've got a
rook and there's just nothing there's no
more problems that can be created from
White's point of view he maybe start
thinking about Bishop h3 Bishop e6
Bishop takes Queen c6 getting his pieces
out you might just go rookie to rook
over to e1 and eventually want round
that guy up and there's nothing black
can really do further let's go back
let's go back so bad Vinick rook ahead
what the heck he can afford to be
generous sacrifices the exchange in
order to grasp victory takes takes takes
Knight takes d5 very simple Queen a for
another one of those meddlesome mistakes
again from bad Vinick when Bob Vinick
played Queen a four you thought
doubtlessly he thought I got this game
in the bag all I got to do is keep
trading down and my extra piece will
will win the game this is another small
error he should have played the simple
Knight takes d5 Queen takes d5 and in my
opinion King e2 now you don't want to go
castles because the bishop is hanging
but king e2 is absolutely fine there's
no attack that that black can achieve
the worst he can do is again to be
annoying to grab some pawn now Black has
two pawns for a bishop but it's really
bad sorry Julian yet
F or here I don't know what you're going
to do over there
I thought that King e2 was just
supporting my Queen to come back and
consolidate I don't know continue Queen
a2 here
so this is again pretty simple I think
I'm just going to go here and if you go
here this was like a kind of a trance
trance position of what I could get with
the Queen versus rook but if I want to
be a little bit I don't know
I say bold I could probably go mmm rook
c1 I don't know
let me try now I like Queen d3 Queen d3
is a good move
maybe I just go rook here so I'll keep
my I keep I keep the goods hey I keep
the pawns you could trace on e3 but
you're running out of ways of really
being able to give me problems yeah
unfortunate but in any case kingi 2 was
the right move pardon me not part of me
Knight takes d5 in this position
followed by king e2 and I think
authentic would have been in good shape
smooth sailing instead Queen a4 and now
the ship takes III and it's sort of like
man you know moment ago he was a rook
down now he's a piece down but he's got
two ponds but even worse is if you look
at the pawn structure black all of
back spawns are intact it may look
really good
there's nine on a four is a little bit
stupid it's offside this pawn on b2 is
nobody's favorite and you know now it's
really nettlesome know it's not easy at
all
rook comes sliding over b3 the problem
with the immediate Bishop c4 if I
remember was Bishop c4 rook takes Bishop
takes king over to f8 now you can't take
thanks to a back rank you have to come
kingi to but then there's takes and rook
d4 check so b3 was bought vinick's booth
and now it's a real game like what the
hell just happened
you don't like you're playing for the
World Championship you blunder the rook
and look at this
you know you right back in it now every
time this kind of thing is happening
like you know your opponent you know
who's expecting you to resign and been
expecting your resign for the last few
moves they're getting more and more
frustrated right because it's a little
like you know you're lucky lucky chump
man he's getting away with murder over
here
rook c1 rook b8 Knight c3 Knight before
it's really masterful that's the only
word I can use to describe Bronstein's
play from this point onwards it's sort
of like he gets to do everything he
wants the rook asifa the seafood the
rook on the C file has been closed in a
dream world this pawn on B 3 is
blockaded in a dream world black a place
C 6 d5 King e7 king d5
and start running at with a central
avalanche Bishop e2 I didn't like that
move I thought that was wrong
yes I thought that bad Vinick should
have played rook a 1 with the idea that
after king eise Evan Arne let me just
put this move at least in this variation
he would have a an active rook if black
puts his King pardon me if you're black
puts his King on d7 you could harass
white could play Bishop b5 check and
force him back Julian
exactly let's have a look at that sorry
the question is I thought that the best
move was rook a1 and Julian as asked in
that case why can't we take this bishop
and take on b3 and the answer is after
rook a7 what you really want to do is
play the move d5 the problem with d5 is
definitely not rook takes excuse me
escape
definitely not rook takes set c 7d for
the king c2 and the problem is Knight
takes d5 if you can't play d5 then this
rook on the seventh like a really
horrible thing to allow would be
something like rook takes e7 and then
Knight d5 in the future that's like a
not good it just it's it's a knight
versus pawns and the Knights are simple
the knight is simply stronger in this
particular case but that was not
authentic by the knick played Bishop e2
rook a8x glam Knight a four c6x glam
rook c4 and rook b8 so it's sort of like
in those last sequences of moves this
night has moved from c3 to a4 not
particularly good the rook is a little
bit better on c4 but not that much
better but now black has this beautiful
blockade and blacks moves are getting
easier and easier
King e7 d5 King d6 and bad Vinick has to
start to think okay time to real things
in and you know like shut things down
Bishop d3 King e7 Knight B to d5 again I
remember playing over this game as a kid
and thinking to myself I like that
structure you know I really like these
bonds
d 5 now white had better be really
careful here what would you do if your
white keep in mind that essentially if
Black gets to play E 4 on his next move
this night on b2 is doomed to a really
awkward existence black is planning to
go D efore king d6 king e5 and support
his pawns what do you do with white
don't all answer at once then what do
you think what would you do but then
you're really under a lot of pressure at
rook c5 essentially you're kind of
encouraging black to do what he wants to
do King d6 Julian
exactly that's a I mean now it was like
bad Vinick was was trying to save the
game it wasn't you know some but you
can't allow black to just get in all of
his moves now after the tempo move h5g
four is what bought Vinick played in
order to break up and we get some
activity for his pieces takes takes f4
well again after that little operation
black spawn still his villa
scary g5 so in order to prepare a rope
check without allowing King f6
rook FA this was a really fine move I
was really impressed by this move when I
played over the game and hold on what
move are we at sorry II for rook takes
King e5 and the game was adjourned here
the game was adjourned and much to my
surprise the players agree to a draw
whoa so I'm sure David Bronstein was
thrilled and delighted at giving
spotting rook odds to mod minute
and drawing the game but on the other
hand if you kind of look at the position
and kind of go whoa wait a minute
you know f3 king d4 III check this looks
really amazing why did the players agree
to a draw why didn't brunch team play
this out and the best that I came up
with was this move Bishop g4 okay so the
idea becomes obvious in just a moment
you got to play a3 you
to get that guy going and then it was
this check that was annoying
now you can't step to f4 if you go king
f4 oops and suddenly that's a no no no
so you have to step to e Phi too deep
from i-5 to d4 and now comes look at
6:00 anyway ok you can't afford to trade
rooks and then comes the sacrifice and
we get this position now wait a minute
whites upon up but he's threatening to
go g6 or rook g3 and g6 and the best I
could see was that they were going to
make a repetition back and forth well as
for I mean it's not beautiful but as far
as World Championship match games go I
mean it was sure fun I can imagine but
the audience is sitting down and seeing
their player down a rook with an inside
of a dozen move and a grandmaster lee
draw uh uh who is the finish yeah very
the whole game so that was I mean a very
very entertaining World Championship
match one of the things that I found
very interesting and going over many
games of this match was how whelmed well
match the players were I mean there
wasn't a lot of difference between the
two players and we'll all remember the
famous
game that Bronstein lost that he had to
draw and he just made one move blunder
their match finish 1212 yeah but the
rules at the time were that
the in case of a drawn match the players
were declared vice champions if you will
but bad Vinny kept the title so that
meant that Bob Vinick would have to wait
for his Challenger and Bronte would have
to chaff to go through the whole process
of inner zone zonals inner zonals
candidates to get back and he didn't
make it
vassilisa me slopped it any questions
it's all good
all right until next time we will look
at more drama spills and thrills from
World Championship match games thank you
have a good evening